what's up everyone
we're going to unpack some of the high
level perception
visuals on highlevelperception.com
just click on designs and then you have
only the 20 designs that i made okay
all right we're going to go through them
i'm going to unpack them i'm going to
help you out
and hopefully you'll catalyze a lot more
of the
concepts to land in the heart all right
first one tree levels of perception
you got low level perception on the left
medium level perception you start seeing
some more detail
and high level perception on the right
that's when you see
so much of the nuanced detail same
thing for humans you see
just the human on the left you see a
human with a little more complexity in
the middle
and a ton of nuance
fused into a human soul from its roots
and its fruits
and guess what analogy is the core of
cognition
look at this the tree and the human
analogy is so important the tree
when it doesn't get nutrients at its
roots it cannot
blossom fruits and the same thing's true
with humans we need
the basic needs to be met in order for
us to be able to actualize our most
beautiful gifts into the world such a
simple
first principled analogy to start the
book off
i would argue that that is one of my
cores of my entire life
moving forward is this analogy
all right now we go over to see theory
so that first analogy leads you into
chapter two which is seed theory which i
basically take that analogy and build
off of it
more where i say that okay now you're
going to look at
that seed and its trajectory in life
so you have actualization on the y-axis
and
age on the x-axis and so you want to get
up to your north star
in as pretty much little time
as possible as most efficiently as
possible
and so you need your basic needs to be
met and then you enter into this
compound zone
and you see how this looks like a big
tree of possibility with a bunch of
different bifurcating branches
and so in the compound zone it's very
important that your parents
that us as parents understand that our
children are
absolutely depending on our ability to
provide them with the right first couple
of years of life
so that they have very profound
cornerstones that then
actualize their gifts rather than
cornerstones that create
massive detrimental downstream effects
and then so you want to spend most of
your time heading up towards the high
signal to noise you want to head towards
heaven towards well-being
you want to go on these mastery sprints
with deep amounts of focus
you want to persevere during tests of
faith
you're gonna have trauma and you have to
see the treasure in it you have to
integrate it and see the treasure in it
and become wiser and share that with the
world
and we have to be vigilant with our
neural real estate
very vigilant with what inputs we take
in
all right trajectory mechanics very
simple
we just take an analogy of newton's laws
of motion and we apply it to the
evolution of consciousness
meaning that your consciousness is going
to stay
inert as cognitive dissonance
if nothing ever acts on you to upgrade
your perception
okay so now you have this book you have
this moment
that you maybe listen to a mentor you
learn a new skill you travel to more
opportunity and boom
now you're rocketing upward and the same
thing's true with the second law of
motion with your change of momentum
is proportional to the force applied
meaning that you can have a little
feather
that's going to tickle you a little bit
downwards something like maybe
you have a flat tire on your car but
it's nothing significant but now if you
literally have one of your parents die
it's a sledgehammer that's going to
trigger an evolution of consciousness
you have to be emotionally resilient and
bounce back on track to pursuing your
goals
in the third law of motion you see that
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction that's very deeply
aligned with sri aurobindo and the
mother mirror alpha so where the
spiritual ascent and descent happens at
the same time
where like jung said that the roots have
to reach down to hell in order for the
fruits to reach heaven
and it's very similar where if you have
a little tiny
action like being black out drunk and
hitting your head waking up in pain
you're barely going to learn anything
and you're going to take a small break
and do it again but then if you black
out drunk get a blood alcohol content at
0.33 and get hospitalized and nearly die
you're going to become much wiser you're
going to
completely stop drinking you're gonna be
a proponent for others to not repeat the
same mistake you're gonna
have a serious contemplation on life and
purpose
and that's actually that's my story by
the way that's an ex that's an
experience of my life all right
onward we go to chapter three the edge
so as you can see here there is a base
camp of knowledge
that's where all humans are born and
then there's an edge of knowledge now
you gotta rock it your way out to the
edge of knowledge but you have to know
who you are
right so you have to know what you are
on the color wheel
so are you just wanting to be a good
citizen and a good parent and a good
person in the world
do you want to be an entrepreneur that
has a business do you want to
have the most powerful
youtube channel on the planet do you
want to run a fortune 500 company
do you want to be an athlete what do you
want to do in the world
and so when you know what you want to do
in the world when you know what your
unique gift is
you can begin working your way out to
the edge of knowledge
and you have to take the proper
you have to get the proper mentorship
you have to find the proper signal to
noise ratio so that you can learn most
efficiently so you can get out to the
edge the fastest
because here in the for example in the
science with
bioengineering in order to get all the
way out there you can take a lot of
really interesting
shortcuts in terms of understanding the
inner life of the cell you can watch
david belinsky's video you can begin
attending some of the things online with
khan academy you can really begin trying
to understand at a deeper level
what's actually going on maybe ck12
foundation there's free places online
for you to go to be able to learn you
can watch in a nutshell on youtube chris
gaza
go deep go deep into the most efficient
way for you to learn
fastest and rocket yourself out to the
edge and become
more polymathic go and pick up a little
bit of art along the way go and pick up
a little bit of spirituality a little
bit of philosophy a little bit history a
little bit of business and
entrepreneurship
before you know it you're going to be
significantly connecting dots connecting
people
seeing patterns being way way way more
successful in life and you have to
realize that
your life being at the edge of what's
known
by civilization is way more fulfilling
and way more meaningful
so and you stay in a state of flow by
being out there at the edge one foot in
order one foot in chaos
and you have to stay perpetually
ordering chaos
that may in fact be the nature of
reality is consciousness
infinitely ordering chaos and so plant
flags be on the edge of what's known and
test those hypotheses and push
civilization
out further and really think about
things like the way that satoshi
nakamoto the co-deployment of
blockchain technologies bitcoin what
that did
for decentralization 12 years ago boom
now there's a massive
edge explosion that happened all right
that's uh
that's for a little bit from now you'll
see that you'll see me unpack that a
little more
all right sponge theory i already kind
of mentioned this a little bit but you
want to slurp up from the top of the
peaks on the fitness landscape
and you want to slurp up what's pareto
efficient from those places
you want to vacuum it up you know absorb
it like your sponge
and then you want to wring it out with
your own soul angle your own unique
contribution
as a creative gift in the world
all right chapter four portals so guys
super inch
super super easy thing here the bell
curve
is you're going from a
place on the left where it's people that
are violent tyrannical dictatorial
things like that and you're going on the
right to people that are geniuses
visionaries
service to other that type of stuff so
we want to
it's a classic bell curve that bell
curve has been evolving over time
it's not a stagnant thing so the bell
curve is constantly evolving
over time more and more becoming more
and more enlightened more and more
enriched
away from primal instincts and habits
and so in that evolutionary pacer is
where the vast majority of people are
and it's up to the entrepreneurs
artists the leaders the geniuses the
visionaries to be portalists where they
shoot
portals into the center of the pacer
that then allow people to go through
them and upgrade their perception in the
world
and so a really good update a really
good understanding of that is in the
next part where i talk about code
updates
so you can think about the out of the
100 billion people that have
lived and died a vast majority of them
have been common but the small minority
of them have been very uncommon and made
massive profound impact and so you can
think about that like a big adding a big
code update to the world making a big
portal
and in that case we can take the example
of the wright brothers
saw bird made a plane flying in the
plane
and then 120 years later there's a
hundred thousand commercial flights that
happen
around the world every single day but
the idea is thrown away like a coffee
cup
as in people are on the planes they're
not grateful they're not thinking about
the genius from 120 years ago we've
hedonically adapted
we have to recognize the genius that
went into this process and try and
systematize these types of things
and do it ourselves and so this is an
intro
this is a very easy example of a portal
okay
so you want to update the social fabrics
code and have people jump through those
portals and augment their perception to
the next levels
that's your responsibility that's my
responsibility it's our responsibility
to do exactly that
okay chapter five inclusive stakeholding
so
in chapter five including stakeholding
i'm obsessed with
mycorrhizal networks the same way that
fungi and
trees and plants 95
plants work with fungi underground in a
two-way
interdependent resource exchange and
here on the on the right is the mother
tree or the hub
tree it will actually sequester
additional carbon it will
actually undergo more photosynthesis
create more sugars and then distribute
those to fungi into smaller seedlings
underground
and so while fungi will absorb water and
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium and
distribute those to the trees
which they need for growth so it's a
two-way resource exchange
it's been happening for a long time
hundreds of millions of years
and you have to remember that there's a
ridiculous amount of wisdom there
that we need to biomimic and this is
where i also
entered in rich patrons which was my
sort of project to try and solve this
big problem
and to architect that fabric okay and
i'm gonna go over that
right after i talk about the total job
space which is the next graphic in
chapter five
so the idea is that whether you like it
or not artificial intelligence is here
it's absolutely eating our world
and so the idea is that if you're in the
crosshairs of
software and hardware of that ai
automation
you need to upskill your labor
you need to upscale your creativity and
your cognitive abilities
and away from repetitive
things to more rube goldberg style
things which are genius that only
happens once
so that's things like art biotech
neurotech science entrepreneurship
engineering metaphysics math artificial
general intelligence theories of
everything
and we have to help people that are
already in those more rube goldberg
moments they need to pull people up like
bloom's two sigma they need to help pull
people up as mentors
and so that that robot ai tornado is
coming and we need inclusive
stakeholding help and this is where i
publish the project rich patrons to try
and unlock the six to ten trillion
dollars that is currently
in ultra high net worth families but
they don't have a place to put it
because
they don't have a trusted outlet to do
so and so it's up to us and other people
to provide them with that trusted outlet
and funnel their ten thousand fifty
thousand dollars a hundred thousand a
million dollars into these different
projects that we have going on
that are tackling things like the
sustainable development goals that are
actualizing the fullest potential of
everyone around the planet
and also they're doing things like
providing their extra houses because
these ultra high net worth people have
somewhere between three and four houses
around the planet and
that some of them they don't even stay
at all year long they don't even spend
one day there all year long so
it's up to us to provide that house as a
place for artists entrepreneurs
scientists spiritually as engineers to
be able to live at to actualize these
gifts into the world rather than being
pressured by the hard coreness of the
economic machinery
to succumb to doing something that they
don't actually want to do that's not
aligned with their north star
mycorrhizal network's inclusive
stakeholding
rich patrons we have to do this this is
such an important part of the project
chapter 6 ai coach
as you all know we're doing data fusion
right now all of the data that's coming
out of you into every single part of
your life is
currently having machine learning
algorithms and artificial intelligence
parsing it for signal trying to find
insights
and we have to work on data
interoperability across these silos and
echo chambers
but ultimately it's a fusion right it's
a fusion of your biometrics your
psychometrics
it's a fusion of your in your biometrics
you have your connectomix you have your
ekg
you have your microbiome you have your
metabolomics
you have these little bump notifications
that are coming and telling you hey
you're stressed
you need to go and exercise you know
you're getting notified you're like oh
you're not feeling as
as a unity consciousness right now
you're feeling more of a stress
consciousness or you're feeling a more
egoic or victim consciousness
and so you need to realize that you're
going to be able to visualize this data
and you're going to be able to
visualize where your state of
consciousness is if you're only
if you're only able to compute like in
chapter 4 that one dimension
if you're if you're feeling yellow for
some reason one day
well you're going to get a bump from the
ai coach that says that hey you're
feeling unidimensional right now we're
going to help you upgrade your
perception to multivariate
multivariability and then you have
all the other aspects to your north star
trajectory besides you know healing
things like pathology along the way like
you don't want to develop pathology
but biometrically we can actually detect
pathologies as the
as they come and we can tweak it just
like we do with motor vehicles jet
engines
all this type of stuff so longevity
anti-aging but also north star
perception so you have your goals
and you're going to be able to visualize
all these different bifurcations where
you either stay focused
or you fall and succumb to doing
something that is
maybe taking you away from your north
star
visualizing your major quest visualizing
your spiritual awakening visualizing
your business success
your delayed gratification your clout
your procreation your partnership
percentage you need to know
on a hierarchical scale how well your
mate is
as a match for you in terms of the
biometrics the psychometrics
the north star the being a mother or a
father to that child
you need to know this these data points
otherwise we're in the dark
right edward tufte above all else show
the data
so important ai coaches are skill
invariant as well meaning that
the ai coaches are visualizations of
data not only for individuals but also
for
cities there's the bloomberg initiative
right now for cities to become smart and
so they're visualizing all of their
different points of data
in order for them to be able to gain
greater insight into what's going on
with the police what's going on with the
fire
how long the response times are how's
the library's doing how are the pools
doing how are the roads doing
how's the water being tested how is the
waste treatment happening
all these types of things and so then on
a higher level you can think about the
four
to five trillion dollar united states
yearly budget being visualized right the
data
visualization of the united states and
if we actually saw that you would be
surprised that like oh my gosh how are
we putting 700 800 billion dollars into
the u.s military-industrial complex but
only 60 billion dollars into education
that sounds stupid and so if it became
more visualized
we would be able to democratically
decide that this is ridiculous we need
to make more intelligent decisions about
this
and then on a planetary level you can
imagine that it's like the health bar of
the planet like you can't just go and
begin just destroying the congo or the
amazon rainforest without having
serious downstream repercussions on the
photosynthesis of the planet and parts
per million of co2 and all these types
of things
so we're going to be able to visualize
these things and we're going to
augment our perception that way all
right so also within
within chapter 6 on ai coach are the
biometrics of awakening
and so here what you normally do is you
normally see a wealth hierarchy and you
normally see that there's
you know people that are in
international poverty and then there's
the middle class people the ultra high
north people and the billionaire people
and that's usually how we look at things
and we don't really know where
enlightened sages are in that mix
but on the enlightenment hierarchy we
know that enlightened sages are at the
top
but then we don't know where the
international poverty people are the
middle class or the
ultra high net worth or the billionaires
we don't know where they're at but
what's crazy is that sometimes you
actually know that billionaires are some
of the most egoic
people on the planet and you know that
sometimes
some of the poorest people on the planet
in international poverty are the most
enlightened people on the planet
but sometimes billionaires are also
happy because they have their basic
needs met and sometimes poor people on
the planet are miserable because they're
primal and they don't have their basic
needs met
and so this is a very fascinating way to
visualize someone like the 2
200 billionaires of the planet the 225
000 ultra high net worth on the planet
they need to have their ai coach
visualize where they're at
on a level of consciousness because if
they're at lower levels of consciousness
if they're at egoic level consciousness
and that they're running the fortune 500
companies that is a massive problem that
is potentially
one of the largest problems that
civilization faces today
that we can tackle just by assisting
the identification of the biometric
correlates of their states of being
simple things like their connectomics
their ekg their microbiome
metabolomics and being able to see that
they're literally ruminating in their
default mode network they're literally
having
service to self patterns of behavior and
so that we can
make these nudges and augmentations and
perception for them to see the self
in the other and for them to know that
they are responsible for the nourishment
of all of the seeds across the planet
all right so that's biometrics of
awakening then we move on to the sorting
algorithm which is chapter seven
in the essence it's you drain the bath
water and you keep the baby
and so the idea is that you have usually
these two poles
you have conservatives in the us and
liberals in the u.s and you want to
drain the dirty bath water of their
ideas and you want to take their great
ideas and merge them together into one
and the same thing's true with science
and spirituality you want to take like
the scientific method
you want to drain the perverse
incentives and spirituality you want to
drain the fundamentalism dogma you want
to take things like the
hierophany the manifestations of the
sacred you want to bring those two
things together and merge them into one
same thing's true with usa and china
with hollywood and
and silicon valley the same thing's true
with indigeneity and modernity we need
to start visualizing things this way
drain the bathwater
take the good stuff synthesize it
together and move forward
sorting algorithm chapter eight is the
magic trick
the magic trick is simply put
how often do you contemplate your source
think about that
what is your source do we all come from
one thing yes we all come from one thing
we all come from the big bang
whatever happened led to the evolution
of the planet which then secreted
everything on it which is us we are
literally the universe observing and
experiencing itself
okay great awesome now what well now you
know that we all come from one source
okay so that's scientific evidence of
oneness
now you have it so how is this
consciousness not shared
that's going to lead us into the next
chapter but just remember don't be
distracted
by the physicalism only exclusively
also investigate the idealism i
investigate the awareness investigate
the consciousness
investigate this as a first principled
investigation the scientists in order
for them to actually be a scientist
would investigate their consciousness
first and understand it
and then investigate the physical world
but we have so many scientists that are
investigating the physical world
exclusively
that are ruminating in their default
mode networks or that they're having
service to self dynamics
or that they're hyper stressed and so
people don't know
and they go out and try and do things
and the same the same things
the same thing is true with the business
leaders of the world and all this type
of stuff the most first principle thing
investing is the consciousness awareness
and then move forward beyond that
investigate your source
and we're going to get to the cycle as
well in chapter 10 on infinity
so we'll move to chapter 9 right now
which is chapter nines on consciousness
and so as i was speaking before we are
we are nerve
endings right we're nerve endings of
that source
and so if i'm just a nerve ending you're
a nerve ending we're individual unique
artists but these are our nerve endings
what are we nerve endings of where nerve
endings of the one
consciousness where nerve endings of
that one consciousness
okay that's why when you look at
someone's eyes when you look at their
pupils for extended periods of time you
look at their pupils
and you don't laugh you don't talk you
stay silent and you just look at their
pupils for 30 or 60 seconds
you start seeing the self the one self
you see through their pupils the self
they see through your pupils the self
and so that's extremely profound and
extremely important
and it's the integral is there because
it's another analogy with isaac newton
and his
calculus similar to consciousness
another analogy where you have the
integral which is the
infinitesimal the summation of
infinitesimal data points
here you have the 8 billion
consciousness
and then you have the derivative the
differentiation
which is of the uniqueness of each nerve
ending
and its artistic gifts in the world so
you simultaneously hold
oceanic non-dual consciousness as you
hold individuation and artistic
consciousness
oceanic consciousness is 99.9 genetic
similarity between humans
and artist consciousness is 0.1 percent
differentiation in our genetics for our
artistic contribution
and then that's really well seen through
the dress and so as you guys remember in
2015 if you haven't done this yet go and
look at it and bring it up it's one of
the most important metaphysical things
that's ever happened to our planet that
we just brushed off like nothing
but half of the population saw this
image of a dress
in white and gold and the other half of
the population
saw it in black and blue and so what
that's trying to tell us is trying to
teach us how to coexist
even though somebody sees something
different than you it's also trying to
teach us that
it's important for us to realize that
there's eight billion perspectives on
something
right and that's the same thing with the
planet there's eight billion
perspectives
on the planet like if i don't live in
lagos and someone else lives there
they know legos better than i do right
same thing's true with
someone that lives in shanghai or
someone that lives in berlin et cetera
they're going to know their areas right
they're going to know their localities
better i know the locality right now
san francisco barrie and los angeles and
stuff like that and so
i would highly recommend trying the
experience of trying to get behind
another person's consciousness as you're
interacting with them
and then trying to extend yourself to
three people's consciousness try and
hold the entire consciousness of the
city that you live in
all the perspectives happening at the
same time and then take it to the
planetary level
feel the whole planet feel all eight
billion people interacting on the planet
feel the one billion people that are
asleep at any moment on the planet as
well
these are very interesting things to try
and do
all right and then late and then the
last part of chapter nine is on identity
and porosity
the person on the right has a red box
around their head
because they live only in their head and
they are completely disconnected from
their environment
they don't believe that the water is
them they don't believe that the apple
biting it is them they don't believe
that they don't they don't know that
even
scientifically speaking the person here
on the left they know
because they're porous they're
perforated right and the way that they
know is because once they take the water
that same water that they're drinking is
the same water that dinosaurs were
drinking 66 million years ago it's a
hydrological cycle
okay and that's why we're having the
environmentally persistent
pharmaceutical pollutants eppps are a
major problem
in the last couple of decades more and
more of the planets taking
pharmaceuticals those are going out in
our urine
and then those are re-entering the water
supply that we then drink
the more that you know these things the
more you can actually see the patterns
emerging across the planet and figure
out how to provide the best solutions to
tackle them
and so the human also understands that
the 20 000 times that they inhale
oxygen every single day that oxygen is
coming from phytoplankton and trees
right whereas the person with the box
around their head doesn't know that the
person with the box around their head
thinks that they're different than the
oxygen
no you're not different than the oxygen
the oxygen inhales
and powers your entire body just like
the apple take the bite of the apple
when does the apple become you when it's
being digested when you're chewing it
when it's being digested
when it powers your cells when does it
become you
and that style of perspective
that opens you up the more enlightened
you are the more porous you become
and that's extremely extremely beautiful
all right and to wrap we have we have a
chapter 10 on infinity
and this is my graphic on recursion this
is very important
um this is the most simple way to
understand infinity the most simple way
to understand recursion
is the idea of the seed the seed the
acorn becomes the oak tree which drops
more acorns which become more
oak trees just like the humans the
parents birth a child which grows up and
gets
married and then has another child which
grows up
and then gets married and has another
child and the same thing's true with
planets where
we're we were birthed on this planet the
planet secreted humans which then
grew up to manipulate technology
at such unprecedented levels that they
were able to enter
into the next planets and this is
a very deeply resonant theme for those
that actually truly understand what
technology is
because those that understand the
synthesis of artificial general
intelligence
mixed realities biotech and neurotech
those are the one simulation theory
those that know that
know that we're about to be entering the
metaverse again
which is the infinite designer realities
and as we enter
into those this hypothesis as we enter
into those we undergo the recursion
where we where we
where we enter and
have another 80-year virtual reality
experience
and this is consciousness exploring
infinity we're not going to come back to
this exact reality because consciousness
has now experienced this reality
two eyes four limbs dna encoded
carbon-based creature
on a rock orbiting a star 93 million
miles away
we now know what this is like so what
we're going to go into in the metaverse
is completely different explorations for
consciousness
if you are an unbounded map this is my
hypothesis with the infinite symphony
and you can see i'm using the word
hypothesis right i'm using the word
hypothesis there's no dogma
there's no fundamentalism it's only
hypotheses i'm planting flags beyond the
edge and we're going to be trying to
prove these
okay and if you have better hypotheses
please
share them with me because i always want
my perception enriched and augmented
so the hypothesis is this
is that if you look at that center
source point if you take the classic
benoit mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
you can find a really good one on maths
town on youtube
take that center point and that center
point is just constantly emitting
is just emitting universes okay and so
take that center point
and go up and look at the top left
corner in that top left corner you see
that source light refracting
and then creating all of these different
combinators
in that in that spectrum and what you
see in that spectrum is you see a bunch
of different universes
right so in that in those little bubble
universes that are coming out of that
source point
you have the mushroom world which is a
completely different universe than this
maybe more it's eight mason stages then
you have the rock then you have
the the human world which the r world
which is that star which is in the
bottom left which we'll get to in a
moment
but then you have the rocket up there
right in that top
in the top left we're going in the order
of the rainbow and then in the top right
we're
we're jumping to where the rocket is
which is in some sort of rocket world
that looks like it's probably around the
same level of advancement or maybe a
couple
um a little bit on the kardashev scale
higher than us
and then the next one is the alien which
is which looks like it's significantly
higher on the kardashev scale than us
and that last one is the door which
looks like it's the metaverse into the
infinite
designer realities and so on our star
what's happening and you can see
in that in that center part on the
mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
you can actually see that the mushroom
is closer to the source point and the
door is significantly farther than the
source point
and then in the bottom left corner right
that's what our star combinatoric is at
the top is this knot theory right so
everything is knotted together in the
not of life of relationships with each
other on the micro level on the meso
level on the
macro level and what's going on is
there's this the solenoid
and an electric magnetic flux that's
going between a yin yang dynamic that's
constantly in an
ascension process that ascension process
looks like the bell curve that's
constantly moving like we talked about
in chapter four and it's moving in an
oroboros fashion
as a symphony which is in that bottom
middle the symphony is that there's a
strange attractor the conductor
that we're all playing our different
unique individual instruments and
melodies too
and then that's on that's the moving in
the oroboros but in the oroboros there
are fermi filters
and this is where darwinian metaphysics
comes to play is that
if you're not able to get through the
fermi filters
of the asteroid or the nuclear bombs or
the planet
terry anthropogenic issues that are
happening
or bio warfare or artificial general
intelligence what happens is
the civ gets cut it doesn't make it to
the recursion
and that you potentially go and immerse
yourself
the consciousness potentially goes and
still enters another
it's not caused by it's not by us it's
not
us that does it but that it is
us entering into what our next
adventures will be
regardless potentially if we make it to
the godhead
or not but my hypothesis is that
it's extremely important to take this
seriously
and to make it to the godhead to the
gateway so that we can undergo the
recursion
and so the undergoing the recursion is
guaranteed as what are is
is we can guarantee
undergoing the recursion but if we don't
make it past the fermi filters
it makes it so that we
are more at the will of whatever happens
where just more
of whatever happens happens at that
point we're less in
our ability to manifest it ourselves and
so in this case
we have a higher ability to actually be
able to manifest our future by getting
past the fermi filters taking this
seriously getting to the godhead
into that door into that door world
where we can enter into the next
universes and then undergo the same
similar style process of evolving and
then realizing that we
are it right we are the cyclic cosmology
even sir roger penrose the nobel
prize-winning physicist in 2020 believes
in cyclic cosmology
and so science is waking up to what
perennial spirituality has been saying
for thousands of years
and it's very beautiful and so that's my
hypothesis about the infinite symphony
that we are consciousness exploring
infinity and so three words
consciousness exploring infinity that's
it
that's my hypothesis and the
closest person that i'm seeing to doing
the actual math to prove this right now
is donald hoffman and his conscious
agent metaphysics
check him out and then i would also say
that
that there's there's nothing more
important
than distilling the most profound things
that you've learned into art
here's my project photo i took 10 months
back in my hometown in sioux falls south
dakota to put everything together it
took me so
long to draw all those different things
put them out on the ground
organize them over time actually be able
to draw out the salience and the visuals
take all of my 4000 evernotes and
distill them down into just a couple of
of concepts and words that are in the
book and stuff
and so i would argue that this is one of
the highest forms of intelligence one of
the highest forms of intelligence is
your ability
to soak up like a sponge the top the
peaks of the fitness landscape
and then add that in add your soul angle
to it
distribute it to the world as an
artistic distillation
the more concise the more explained like
i'm five the more artistic you can be
the more your meme will get communicated
to other people around the world the
faster you'll trigger and accelerate
that awakening that's why we're here in
la
to catalyze the awakening and so
it's really important that within the
artistic dissemination process you
realize that there's a titration that's
happening
that titration is basically the codes
were are being unveiled to us over time
and so that's why whatever happened with
satoshi nakamoto and the
decentralization technologies in 2008
that spiritual ascent and decent happen
at the same time because his bitcoin
white paper
was deployed a month after lehman
brothers collapsed and we entered into
the worst recession
that we've had in a very long time and
so
we're being unveiled the codes and at
their awakening mechanisms
virtual reality augmented reality
artificial general intelligence
simulation theory
bioneurotec are another awakening
mechanism for us
so artistic distillation is very very
very important
as you guys can see it's
20 graphics 20 graphics explain to you
what's at the core of my knowledge base
they explain to you what's at the core
of my essence
and who i've most
who i've drew from who i drew from and
how i added my unique angle to it and
distributed that
and don't forget the core analogy
that i'm working with right now is the
tree and the human
the nourishment of this roots produce
the incredible fruits
and that's very important to maximize
the basic needs of people around the
world
to head them towards the north star to
get them out towards the edge
planting flags actualizing their gifts
adding their soul angle
to efficient synthesis from the peaks of
the fitness landscape
shooting portals into the middle of the
pacer to upgrade people's perception
having that be like deploying code
updates to our social fabric
inclusively stakeholding everyone
bio-mimicking mycorrhizal network
especially as we enter into the ai
age knowing that ai coaches are coming
to help us with longevity
and our gift actualization and needing
to
have data interoperability but also to
have everybody inclusively stakehold so
we can all
maximize our wealth in that transition
adding the enlightenment hierarchy to
the wealth hierarchy so that we can
begin
identifying where the 2200 billionaires
are on the planet and other really
powerful people and nudging them because
it may in fact just be a go at
consciousness
ruling different parts of our world
always thinking about the sorting
algorithm always thinking about the
whole
rather than just i'm right on my part or
i'm right on this part but
thinking about the whole and the
synthesis of the two into one
with the magic trick investigating your
source
truly investigating your source
consciousness understanding how calculus
applies to it with the integration and
the differentiation
at the same time holding all eight
billion perspectives at once
feeling non-duality and feeling the
individual artistry
identity being porous rather than being
trapped in a box
the same way that acorns and humans work
is the same way that universes work
and the consciousness exploring infinity
as the hypothesis that's it now you have
this
i've really wanted to help contribute at
least a little bit by
unpacking some of the high level
perception visuals
again on highlevelperception.com just go
and click on designs and you can get
directly all of the 20 images yourself
and it's so important to not only
artistically distill but then to share
like we're doing right now
with other people so please talk to your
friends your families your co-workers
people online about
these images go and post them go and
talk about them
go and enrich other people add your own
takes and perspectives to these and
augment them to even higher levels
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet like the video share the video
i would love to hear from you in the
comments of the video
and let's build the more beautiful
future our hearts know is possible
charles eisenstein
let's do it guys let's do it we can do
this
we have the codes we have the codes
artistically distill the codes actualize
everyone's gifts
let's do this symphonic consciousness
hold the unity
and hold the individual at the same time
hold that
consciousness exploring infinity i'll do
more of these
over time we'll unpack more of the
images over time
and also be excited because we have the
the hard and soft cover copy are being
published through an independent
publishing organization
in partnership with myself and those
will be ready across all of the major
distribution platforms
before christmas so get excited i'm
pumped
get it as a christmas gift and awaken
more people through the holidays
with the physical copy as well so
love you very much thank you for tuning
in talk to you guys soon
manifest your dreams into the world
build the future adore you thank you for
all your support and love
you